bonjour ben c'est à nous les bons jeux
fan ou je sais pas comment le dire
autrement mais je suis dans son corps en
fait oui quand je respire mais c'est sa
bouche qui respire je me regarde dans un
miroir je vois ses yeux son nez ses
oreilles c'était pas bon en fait vous
êtes dans la peau qua non c'est parce
qu'elle veut dire elle prend pas le
problème par le bon bout
je suis en prison dans son corps et moi
et moi dans le sien alors comment on
fait pour s'évader
vous voulez bon diagnostic oui oui ce
serait bien venu je crois tout
simplement que vous êtes amoureux l'un
de l'autre
tu es amoureux ça nous est tombé dessus
comme ça et l'amour sa chambre où tous
les décors les esprits assez simple vous
vous aimez tellement que vous avez
l'impression d'être de l'autre il ya pas
de commande
mais tu vaux mieux que ça m'a poker sont
savamment ce moment
wimereux évidente avait pas un
rendez-vous qui purge en chez le psy
avec l'europe
oui enfin je crois pas ton avoir parlé
mais si c'est en même temps c'est très
important
bush au poids que ce soit intéressé
autant le côté dit pourquoi tu dis ça je
parle l'autre soir mais le toit rebelles
autour d'un thé à la mer dont quoi mais
a vraiment avant laisse tomber info que
yann maintenant mais tu vas au jeu au
bureau travailler en ce qu'a laissé par
la wii
[Musique]
sabri witbooi que je nettoie gestique
samedi de la tête et c'est quoi cette
odeur ça ça c'est du vinaigre blanc
d'ailleurs il faut que t'arrêtes
d'acheter toute sa mère c'est beaucoup
moins efficace en plus ce qu'ils disent
mais c'est une caméra cachée
non c'est de vinaigre blanc c'est ça qui
se dit je sais pas tu fais le ménage tu
prépares à dîner tout ça avec le sourire
j'hallucine ah oui mais peu changé non
plus pose beaucoup tu vois quand même
dentiste est rude alors voilà je chacun
son tour toi tu bosse beaucoup ben ça
c'est à mon tour
est ce que je me dis c'est du donnant
donnant mais tu me trouves non pourquoi
c'est la dernière conçoit comme sa
pierre ça me dérange pas mais taper une
femme ait eu c'était un place tu
comprends rien j'ai pas le choix pas ta
place
[Musique]
venez le président wade 12 heures ta
tête taper sur la tête et c'est quoi
c'est quoi qu'est ce qui se passe on en
fait quoi là on va où à toi tu as tu
cherches une planche à découper pour les
9 ans 1 convient si bien neuf ans déjà
t'imagines ça file et toi alors ben moi
je le fais toi ça va mon coeur n'y pense
même pas génial m2 chacun allait
maintenant que tu fonces moss est
toujours au patron du leurs clients je
sais pas si je serai assez bonne pour
tenir son rôle pierre commence déjà par
ne plus parler tôt au féminin est
d'accord c'est fatigant et toi tu sais
pas ce qui s'est passé j'ai eu mes rêves
j'ai eu la peur de ma vie mais est-ce
que vous l'entendez manuel j'ai une
galerie malheureusement la part de
madame non madame si madame madame
pénélope eric oui oui oui oui oui
bio vidéo s'appelle eric mon chéri bête
appelle bien pennac ma chérie à droite
[Musique]
ça va pas si si si si ça va c'est très
bien
mais tu vas où j'ai au bureau en ce cas
et c'est par là oui oui
[Musique]
ma voiture sortie du gard dit suffit
maintenant je viens d'excusés alors tu
vas te briser les ovaires on chie le
constat thurmond dota savonnette